a ruling class is pretty dismal record
of failure recently from a rock to the
financial crisis to the opioid epidemic
policies set by people in power seem to
have damaged the country and yet no one
who thought any of this stuff up ever
suffers or is held accountable that's
the way it seems anyway Nassim Nicholas
Taleb has been one of the toughest
critics of this arrangement
he's just released a brand new book
called skin in the game hidden
asymmetries in daily life and he joins
us tonight actually
thanks for coming up hi thank you for
inviting me so it seems like one of the
themes of the book is that if you're
profiting from a system you ought to be
at some risk let's say and that causes
the problem of what I call the pseudo
expert you know butcher when you go to
the butcher you know the butcher is an
expert at whatever he or she will be
doing the same with a dentist you can
check on they have downside risk and
they're filtered out there's a filtering
that comes with the fact that they can
they're subjected to evolution they own
their own risk a cook in a kitchen if
cooks something horrible visibly would
be out of business the problem is you
have a class of people who are immune to
that simply because they're not judged
by reality they're judged by one another
in academia in bureaucracies they're not
judged so well you can have pseudo
experts go forever you see a pilot of a
plane is an expert that piloting the
plane but I'm not sure a policy expert
is an expert that anything I think
you're absolutely right it's
demonstrable what's so striking though
is that this principle extends even into
sectors you think would be pure
meritocracies like the finance sector
you have very fine the finance sector
actually in the hedge funds for example
they eat their own cooking so a hedge
fund operator will be subjected to risks
and and would write you know you blow up
you're out of business but in the
banking system for example you can have
managers of banks not pay for losses
because their employees they make the
bonuses when when things are right and
when there's a loss the taxpayer eats it
that's what happened was banking and and
because of revolving door particularly
under Obama bankers got the largest
bonus pool in history in 2010
you see after they lost more money than
ever made in the history of banking so
banking is not immune to the expert
problem but hedge funds are I mean
people they're normal people 99 percent
of America's bear their own risk
yes okay you have 1% not even 1% small
category people they're immune to these
risks because somehow they're judged by
one another and it clicks get formed and
then you start having metastatic
bureaucracies see a hundred years ago if
you take Europe United States these
class of pseudo professional did not
exist ok progressively now that GDP you
know government you know attributed to
the government is rising five to ten
times where it was in Europe that class
is swelling the probably 2030 times what
they were in 1900 so but I guess what's
confusing is so you have a class of
people with no incentive to make good
decisions because there's no penalty for
bad decisions and no I don't think and
no they're making all the key decisions
that were key this is shocked at me how
did that happen that's the right I have
no idea how can you be wrong on
carbohydrates you know what their advice
of what the Americans should be eating
today rule for reminding us it's true
on carbohydrates they were wrong on Iraq
they were wrong on Libya they are now
wrong on Syria okay because there's no
filtering they're not penalized and so
my idea is both empirical of course
these guys know nothing I call them
intellectual yet idiots they're good at
taking exams and some sets of exams and
so select one another so they're
empirically not good and but morally
it's morally unacceptable in never in
history never in the history of mankind
have we had people who were war mongers
without being embattled yes this is the
first phase in history you see that
that's interesting so how would you how
would you reconnect risk to reward well
decentralization is one issue one one
one one obvious solution in Switzerland
decision makers in Washington look at
the next well as
and they're not penalized by but by by
those they're punishing you see insulin
decision has bottomed up the maximum
amount of decisions are taken locally so
you live in a community you have more at
stake than just being elected or not you
have grandkids in the community you have
things your life is there at you own a
place you're part owner of the place so
the more you go from bottom up you see
to top-down type of system the more you
have that class of people and and this
is what the rebellion is the English I
was in the UK last week and talking
about brexit brexit is not about Europe
brexit is about a bunch of bureaucrats
running your life right so what I mean I
guess just for you what are the
implications you're a very well-known
person it globally you're a famous
operator or a lot no I wasn't rated for
a long time okay so that's the question
do they hate you they don't hate me
because it's sort of like for example
economic in the economics profession
given that I'm both the trader and math
not mathematically in the unit
mathematician they sort of don't mess
with me because I come from the field
but but there's one thing I mean I
explained the invite both the election
of Donald Trump to one simple fact
when I see him standing next to
bureaucrats I know he's not one of them
right listen tell I'm I was a trader
someone a butcher would tell ok this
he's not one of them why particular he
has cards having scars means you've done
something you've taken risks in your
life yes
you see and trans risk takers are have
some appeal to the population do they do
i they're they're all more real thank
you what an interesting conversation and
what an interesting book thanks a lot
for that thanks for everybody